en la víspera de la retirada de las
tropas estadounidenses de afganistán
varias columnas de humo negro sobre
kabul este lunes las defensas
antimisiles de eeuu se interceptaron
hasta cinco cohetes que tenían como
objetivo el aeropuerto de la capital y
que impactaron en diferentes partes de
la ciudad sin causar por el momento
víctimas mortales el ataque lanzado
desde este vehículo ahora carbonizado
fue reivindicado por la filial local del
grupo yihadista estado islámico
nuestra casa está aquí estábamos
sentados en nuestra casa cuando ocurrió
una explosión terrible y pensé que un
cohete había impactado en alguna parte
cuando miré por la puerta vi que
disparaban cohetes contra el aeropuerto
desde un automóvil fue un accidente
terrible hubo ruidos fuertes y no
entendí si fueron seis o siete disparos
la gente está aterrorizada y preocupada
por el futuro les preocupa que este
juego de cohetes pueda continuar cosas
el bombardeo se produce después de que
el domingo un drone estadounidense
lanzar un ataque contra un vehículo en
el que supuestamente se encontraban
militantes yihadistas si bien el
objetivo eran los terroristas del estado
islámico al menos 10 civiles entre ellos
ocho menores de edad fallecieron en el
ataque estadounidense un hecho que ha
despertado la ira entre los vecinos y
familiares de las víctimas
cuando llegamos el coche estaba en
llamas y no pudimos encontrar ninguna
parte de los que estaban dentro excepto
un pie de un niño de 12 años
las autoridades estadounidenses no han
confirmado víctimas civiles en su ataque
sin embargo no es la primera vez que un
avión no tripulado de eeuu mata a
civiles en afganistán durante su guerra
contra el terror que inició hace 20 años
y concluirá con la salida de las tropas
estadounidenses el 31 de agosto